to me the pivotal point was what Elon
dis at Twitter now ask yeah I was there
for you go from 8,500 employees to I
believe the latest count is400 or500
that compression while largely not just
maintaining the product but actually
accelerating product experimentation and
and so forth now there's a whole other
discussion whether the business model is
sort of creaking a little bit but that
seems separate from can you run this
company in a more efficient way and I
think once Elon proved the that sort of
at a large scale for a major billion
dollar company the pressure is going to
kick in because you're going to have
investors at other companies going like
why are you so fat Zuck did it Zuck got
rid of working out get leaner get more
efficient because if you don't
eventually not next year maybe maybe not
the year after but in year three
someone's going to show up and they're
going to be ripped